here's how to end procrastination get an
electric dark collar clip it on if you
see me procrastinate just click this
button here okay
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next one
jokes aside i'll give you some very
practical stuff that you can implement
immediately and this is exactly what i
did with dan he asked me to help him
with his phone addiction i've taken a
whole a whole course for nine months
alongside like gamblers to actually get
help with this how much screen time do
you currently have on your phone five
hours per day yeah our goal was to
reduce it to one hour a day here's how
we started see our brain creates strong
habits like procrastination using three
stages that we need to hack one is the
trigger one is the routine and one is
the consequences for example stage one
we see it's wednesday which means it's
chest day stage two is we hit the gym
and stage three is we feel like a king
or we get a notification we check our
phone and we get a dopamine spike and by
strategically optimizing these three we
can set up a system to make it easy for
us to stick to our commitments and
almost impossible to break them if we do
it right the first stage is the easiest
one to implement is already extremely
effective which is the triggers
basically anything that reminds us or
causes us to take in action and by
strategically removing the triggers that
cause an unwanted behavior you won't
even be tempted to do it this is always
in my pocket i'll have it on the table
while i'm trying to work on something
you have the phone in your pocket that's
a trigger think about it who would you
think is more likely to stick to a
healthy diet someone who has no cookies
in his pantry that could tempt him
someone who has a pantry with lots of
cookies in it someone who has a bag of
cookies literally everywhere he goes or
is it maybe someone who literally has it
i know it's a bad example but you get my
point how many times have you bought
fast food just because you saw an ad of
this
juicy
and it just triggered you to want this
thing which you didn't want before but
just by seeing it
these are all triggers do you currently
have the social media apps that you want
to avoid on your phone um i have
facebook instagram why do you have
facebook on your phone
i i don't know so why don't you delete
it right now because
right now you know what delete facebook
all right so when you're feeling
motivated and strong remove the bookmark
to facebook delete the social media apps
put your phone out of sight so you don't
even get tempted get rid of all the bad
food in your fridge and your pantry
until there are no more temptations left
and just by doing that you save so much
willpower because there's so much less
to resist let's see how high we can go
though
no
all right let's turn it on five
ah
i think that's it it doesn't go higher
than five i passed the pain tolerance
test
i'll put it on eight just once just to
see what it's like you gotta experience
some things in life you know
i think i'm gonna go higher than this
you know what number to call if i pass
out right 119.
two days after our first call i followed
up with dan again how did you go um i
didn't remember to put my phone away i
went on facebook quickly just to check
my notifications just on like safari on
my phone's web browser i went on
instagram on the browser so we had to
move on to the next one which is more
powerful than the triggers which is
optimizing the routine trust me this is
a game changer the gist of it is this we
want to make it as easy as possible to
do more of the things that we want to do
and as hard as possible to do the things
that we don't want to do in other words
we want to remove obstacles from the
things that we want to do more of and
set obstacles in place for the things
that we want to avoid see most people
have it the other way around if they
want to go to the gym there are so many
obstacles that make it such a pain for
them to do it and they think about all
the things they need to do first they
have to put on their workout clothes
then pack their bags for the gym then go
out and get into their car drive for 10
minutes maybe 15 minutes and deal with
all the crazy people in traffic then get
lucky to find a parking spot then talk
to the annoyingly motivated people at
the reception then figure out what
workout they actually want to do and
then wait for other people to finish to
use the machines and on the other hand
there are no obstacles that keep them
from slacking off the comfy beanbag is
right behind them the remote is in arm's
reach and yesterday's chips are right
there ready for you to consume
see i understood this very quickly which
is why i set up a home gym all obstacles
removed it only takes me five steps i
put on my clothes go downstairs lift
weights shower finished i think i
skipped a step but you get the point and
that's exactly why dwayne the rock
johnson has a team that sets up his 40
000 pound mobile gym wherever he travels
traveling in a gym like this eliminates
all the excuses not to get the job done
and get to work that's why he's so big
intelligent so we had to set up some
obstacles for dan to stop using his
phone i always try to ruin my experience
with these guilty pleasures we made the
safari browser on his phone incognito by
default so instead of having easy access
he has to type in everything manually to
log into facebook or instagram as well
as the two-factor authentication so
there are multiple obstacles that take
quite some time and we turn on the app
limits function so you have to type in a
code when using certain apps too much
delete your social media apps so you
have to download them if you wanted to
use them which is an obstacle you can
password protect distracting websites
ideally with a very complicated password
time limit your apps and another two
days went by so how'd you go this time i
did pretty much everything that i was
supposed to do for the most part my like
10-day average screen time is continuing
to fall do you think that with what
we've done now this could be a long-term
solution or do you think you could slip
back into old habits i could i could
totally see that happening what if
despite everything you've optimized you
still can't get yourself to follow
through do you think you could get the
three hours down to one hour per day i
feel like i
have some work to get there which brings
me to the final stage which is by far
the most powerful one if nothing has
worked this will no matter how you feel
and you won't even struggle with
willpower anymore this is the ultimate
solution i've done this countless of
times and it worked every single time it
is literally a quick fix you give me a
hundred bucks if you spend too much time
in your phone and you'll send me your
screen time by 10 pm to prove it if you
don't do that it also means you give me
100 bucks that's it maybe you've heard
the backstory of what burning the boats
means basically when conquerors wanted
to take a city or a castle upon arrival
they burned the boats so they either had
to succeed or die trying they just had
to make it happen and by setting up a
system with severe consequences we can
make ourselves do anything that seemed
almost impossible beforehand although i
was joking with the electric dark color
in the beginning it's kind of true the
most inspiring people we look up to were
oftentimes put into a position where
they had no other choice than to step up
and take action and as some of you may
know this is why i started my first
business because of severe pain i was
forced to leave australia because my
visa had run out my australian
girlfriend was still there i promised
her that i would come back but there was
no option for me to actually make it
back unless i built a successful
business and even though it seemed
impossible at first i made it happen and
unfortunately most of us only grow when
we hit severe adversity but let's not
wait for bad things to happen to us so
we can finally step up let's
strategically create it
you did it
this is the least i've used my phone in
like a very long time it feels good man
how can we make this stick long-term i
was thinking of setting up that
structure with my fiance now if you're
sick of not doing what you're meant to
be doing you always have the choice to
set up the system thank you so much and
awesome to see like how quickly i can
change things that seem so impossible
you know like a week ago do you want to
know what i learned from wasting 50 000
on self-help and business courses then
check out this video over here right
here and i'll see you over there uh
you're gonna save yourself some money
i'll see you over there you ambitious
weirdo it actually gives me a warning
now because i put it on 10.
okay i think that's it